ti prendo a testa bella per i ragazzi e
benvenuti noi oggi siamo nuovo horror
con loculo streep ragazzi sono usciti
due di horror nuovi parlò con strip e
non vedevo l'ora di poterli giocare park
a [ __ ] quindi ragazzine che possiamo
cominciare
ok perfetto ragazzi che cazzo resto a
roma siamo in villeggiatura ragazzi
credo sia tipo miami più o meno è una
roba bello fanta sono in un fosso
si va dai video gioco si chiama si
chiama il pozzo quindi credo che sia
giusto 4chan fa un rumore bellissimo
questo pozzo non credo che siano pezzi
cioè una nota fatta non posso dare una
sega la meni io mi guardo in giro
fantastico tanto a bello il cielo rega
pieno di stelle che è un romantico
ragazzi la spiaggia al mare il sole al
tramonto cielo pieno di stelle e
meravigliosa recano in c nient'altro da
dire tanto posso solo fare cristina figo
se mi arrampico sulla sedia tipo di
vento più alto fantastica c'è va bene
non è che possa arrampicarmi
sull'armadio per appello di zio ma chi
cazzo sei laddove minchia spunta la tua
colpita con rialzi questo era abbastanza
corta la soltanto una prova per vedere
com'era adesso se non un pochettino più
lungo ma non penso di essermi mai preso
uno spavento così comunque vi lascio al
video record ragazzi siamo su don't let
di euro non so che cosa è un altro
horror tra l'altro
beh è la sostanza mi sembra più [ __ ] di
camera mia tra l'altro bello spalle
possenti braccia addominali vado in
palestra regala con le braccia che si
muovono quando davanti e berlino e poi
io faccio così tutto il giorno i ragazzi
che nella palestra asd boxe control
button che premente devo devo tenere
premuti sti due tasti così cioè se io
lascio andare i tassi ho perso
praticamente figo nel e delle mode
perché ci sono che cazzo ci fanno le
mosse di ignorare gara la finestra porti
a buttarli io non sempre detto di
chiudere la finestra [ __ ]
mandatemi l'acchiappa mosche subito a
tenere la bocca chiusa mi entrano dentro
non è chiaro che dalla finestra e non è
difficile da capire che bisogna chiudere
la finestra è una cosa abbastanza haiti
è stata un'esperienza incredibile ancora
salve buongiorno rega è che noi siamo
chiuso le finestre per le zanzare adesso
qualcuno deve chiudere le porte per i
dinosauri perché casa c'è un
velociraptor che mi sta buongiorno senta
well un caffè guardi lì no niente caffè
non sanno bene sì però stia calmo quali
chiamati in palestra non le piacerebbe
assaggiare il mio gancio destro bravo
perfetto brave di che si caga addosso
chiudi la porta a scanzo chiudi la porta
niente non chiudono nepa [ __ ] stima
le ducati è in trance pro anche la porta
e non la chiude poi entrano le mosse poi
da è colpa mia perché a rischio sottile
colte giusto
mi sembra ovvio nicotel wellness i suns
carolina forum di ginevra città in
spider anche se da proprio no no ragazzi
no no no no no ragazzi
no no no io ranieri non regali di ragni
noi non ce la fanno sul serio a parte
gli scherzi non ce la faccio non ragazzi
non ce la posso fare
ga no no no no no no no no ragazzi
toglietemi quello schifo non ce la posso
fare
una premessa regista perché io ci ho
paura ho paura di ragni ciò paura no no
no no no no no no che schifo di me che
schifo [ __ ]
no non ce la posso fare nel cast è
andato a riguardo sguardo 18 ragazzi
ragazzi non ci posso fare ragazzi già
paura ho paura non sto scherzando
già perché lei non molla non molla lo ha
mollato
non ho mollato senato andato e non ho
guardato che cazzo succede che cosa
succede ragazzi c'è qualcuno che sta
facendo volteggiare si coltelli fantasma
ci sono dice non so se noi o
l'illusionista che che faccio ste cose
però non lo so dato c'è un fiammifero
bello mi do fuoco ei capelli piuttosto
però non ho capito che cosa stanno
facendo
va beh io
cam ok se si è spento tutto fantastico
barba basta
ok anche se ho vinto
mio dio non ci posso credere no basta
basta misurati [ __ ] no non basta
ragni cos'è c'è un pennarello volante fa
da wingardium leviosa credo che cazzo
bello e allora ti prendo a testa
[Musica]
di merda di merda
[ __ ] che cazzo ciò in testa oh mio
dio ragazzi c'è stata è stata una cosa
pazzesca si doveva dovevo rilassarmi un
attimo e normale però online al da nang
e che dovevo rilassarmi un attimo perché
è stata un'esperienza traumatica a dir
poco però che a uno sceglie rosa
ogni volta che succederà qualcosa di
strano in un gioco qualsiasi mi rifugio
qua che stanno impazzendo
ragazzi che cosa diavolo sta succedendo
direi che possiamo concludere quella che
basta così grazie d'accordo ragazzi re
che possono includere qui visto che non
fai domande se una maglia diversa da
prima e quindi ragazzi servizio è
piaciuto fare sotto commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come lo
divido tra l'altra descrizione non sono
riusciti simmetrici vediamo non possono
vito bella ragazzi